Hello everybody, Dr. Kevin Connors with Section 16 of the Stop Pity Cancer Book.
Good talking about some favorite therapies I love.
Again, if you have any questions, if you're interested in content in our office,
please do so at the number below that you see on this slide.
In this section, we're going to talk briefly on medicinal washers,
maybe my favorite nutraceutical because we've seen it work literally like magic,
like use of work, but it's just amazing how mushrooms work.
Manufacturing a whole presentation on mushrooms on a 20-minute presentation on mushrooms
that's in our clinic, cutters clinic online program.
Because mushrooms are just so phenomenal, I literally honestly didn't use very much
medicinal mushrooms until about five or six years ago.
I don't remember how I got into them, but they started to test out so well on patients
that it just blew my mind.
It's just so beneficial, we've just seen so many great results with medicinal mushrooms
that we use our own special blend of medicinal mushrooms that have more things in there
than just the medicinal mushrooms, but it is just a great, great tool to use.
We use just a powdered blend equivalent to about a tablespoon of our blend
on a daily basis, typically with patients.
It's just a great, great protocol to add.
Also, protocell.
Protocell came in to be eaten a number of years ago as, what was it called?
Can't, can't sell, can't sell.
I forgot what it was called.
It's marketed that same way in Europe now, but in the US it's marketed as protocell.
There's only one company that sells protocell, that distributes protocell.
It's Florida.
We sell it at their cost to our patients that need it as well.
There's two different types of protocell, the protocell 23 and the protocell 50.
What is for most cancers, the other one is mainly for prostate cancer.
protocell is a great program.
We understand it with the protocell literature talks about you can't use it with the right machines,
talking about with an electrical right machine, not the right frequency, right machines.
We use it with the right all the time.
It does test out as well since we started using medicinal mushrooms.
Actually, we had more people on protocell before we started using our own medicinal mushroom blend.
It's much cheaper for patients and just seems to work so much better for patients.
The protocells are a great program.
There's a couple of books on the market.
I should have put a picture on them here of the books.
We sell it in our office because it's a really neat story of a person's personal experience with protocell
that a person had that protocell really helped the chemo work much better.
It was very beneficial.
I understand even though it gave you all this stuff in this book,
I think it would be a horrible detriment not to say that in my belief is that if you did too many of these things,
it could be very harmful for you.
Remember by code of law that anything that you absorb, that your body can't use,
your liver has to detoxify.
If you're taking protocell and mushrooms and a donation and garlic and enzymes and many other things in this book,
and your body really only needs the mushrooms,
all that other stuff has to detoxify through your liver detox pathways.
And you do not want to overwhelm the liver detox pathways of anybody,
let alone somebody who's trying to kill cancer cells.
So too much of a good thing is a bad thing.
Too much of a good thing is a bad thing.
And anything that you absorb, that your body can't use, you have to detox.
Anything that you absorb, that your body can't use, your liver has to detoxify after you will.
You will overwhelm your liver detox pathways.
So you do not want to take things that your body doesn't need.
So you need to have an adequate way to test for that.
So find somebody that can't come to a clinic.
Alright, I hope this has been official for you.
I hope you enjoyed this section.
I will talk to you soon.